The people on 118th Street in New York City are doing this thing that almost nobody in New York or around the country is doing. And to figure out why-- what's it about their block-- I asked a longtime resident, Ivette Rodriguez, to tell me about the place.
纽约市118街的居民们正在做一件纽约乃至全国几乎无人做的事。为了弄清楚原因——也就是这条街有什么特别之处——我请了一位长期住户伊薇特·罗德里格斯（Ivette Rodriguez）为我介绍这里。
And she told me that, when she and her mom moved to the block back in 1965-- this is the very neatly-kept 400 block of East 118th Street, with brick houses and low iron fences where the property line hits the sidewalk. Back when she moved here, the south side of the street was mostly Latino. Her side of the street, the north side, was mostly Italian.
她告诉我，1965年她和她妈妈搬到这条街时——这是东118街400号街区，非常整洁，有砖房，物业线与人行道相接处有低矮的铁栅栏。当时，街道南侧住的大多是拉美裔。她所在的一侧，即北侧，住的大多是意大利裔。
And we got this apartment because I told my mother, don't say a word. Let me talk. Because if they would have found out that we were Puerto Rican, they would not have rented to us. So I just kept really quiet. She kept quiet.
我们能租到这套公寓是因为我告诉妈妈，别出声。让我来说。因为如果他们发现我们是波多黎各人，他们就不会租给我们了。所以我一直保持安静。她也保持安静。
So you guys were passing as Italian.
所以你们假装是意大利人。
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
Her mom now owns the building. These days, Ivette says most of the old Italians are gone, and the block is a mix of Latino, white, and Black. There are lots of retirees-- people who arrived decades ago, like Ivette. And younger people are moving in. So we're talking, and I glance at the clock in her apartment and realize the time.
她妈妈现在拥有这栋楼。如今，伊薇特说大多数老意大利人都搬走了，这条街变成了拉美裔、白人和黑人的混合社区。这里有很多退休人员——像伊薇特一样几十年前就搬来的人。也有年轻人搬进来。正聊着，我瞥了一眼她公寓里的时钟，意识到了时间。
Don't worry. My husband has an alarm.
别担心。我丈夫设了闹钟。
Yeah, no. We're just at two minutes before 7:00 now.
没，不，我们现在离7点还有两分钟。
No, this is 10 minutes fast, just in case.
不，这表快了10分钟，以防万一。
Oh, it is?
哦，是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
OK.
好的。
I was worried about the time because I was there to record something that starts at 7:00. You remember, early in the pandemic, how people would lean out their windows, or go out at 7:00 PM and cheer for the healthcare workers and other essential workers? OK, most blocks around New York City, most blocks everywhere, stopped doing that long ago. But for some reason, not this block. They stayed at it for over 400 days, everyday.
我担心时间是因为我是来记录7点发生的事情的。记得在疫情初期，人们如何探出窗外，或者在晚上7点出门为医护人员和其他关键岗位工作者欢呼吗？好吧，纽约市的大多数街区，到处的大多数街区，早就停止了这种做法。但不知为何，这条街没有。他们坚持了400多天，每天如此。
Yeah, we've got to get ready, Ira.
好了，艾拉，我们要准备一下了。
OK. What do we do to get ready?
好的。我们要怎么准备？
I've got to put on my jacket--
我要穿上夹克——
OK.
好的。
--because I stay out there a long time.
——因为我要在那儿待很长时间。
Soon enough, at 7:00, we head outside, where some very prompt neighbors have already gathered with pans and noisemakers they use every night.
很快，到了7点，我们走到外面，一些非常准时的邻居已经带着他们每晚使用的平底锅和噪音制造器聚集在那里了。
[CLANGING]
[金属敲击声]
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Want to guess at how many people it takes to make this much noise? OK, get a number in mind. Eight. From windows in the apartment across the street, some kids wave flashlights. Standing just inside her fence is one of the neighbors who comes out to watch this every night, Frances Mastrota, 83 years old.
猜猜要多少人才能制造出这么大的噪音？好吧，心里想个数字。八个。在街对面公寓的窗户里，有些孩子挥舞着手电筒。站在栅栏内的是每晚都出来观看的邻居之一，83岁的弗朗西斯·马斯特罗塔（Frances Mastrota）。
I came on this block in 1959 as a bride. I've been a widow since 1975. And I have a granddaughter that is the class of 2019 of Harvard and now is in Chicago.
我1959年作为新娘来到这条街。从1975年起我就守寡了。我有一个孙女是哈佛大学2019届毕业生，现在在芝加哥。
After Frances introduced herself to me in such a deeply grandmotherly way, I actually had to ask a bunch of questions to learn that Frances is Dr. Frances Mastrota, retired oncology researcher, happy to tell me about her work.
在弗朗西斯以一种极其慈祥的方式自我介绍后，我不得不问了一堆问题，才得知弗朗西斯是弗朗西斯·马斯特罗塔博士，退休的肿瘤学研究员，很乐意向我介绍她的工作。
Then as we got better and better, we began to do HLA, Human Leukocyte Antigens, and then look at the genetic code. I'm an old bird.
后来随着我们越来越精进，我们开始研究HLA，即人类白细胞抗原，然后观察基因密码。我这老鸟也懂些。
In fact, this is one of the reasons that this block is still doing the 7:00 appreciation of healthcare workers. A bunch of them on the block worked in healthcare, including Frances, and the neighbor who organized the nightly noise party, Vivian, and Ivette, and Ivette's husband. But there are bigger reasons, I think, that this has continued here every night with all the retirees on the block.
事实上，这也是这条街至今仍保持晚上7点向医护人员致敬的原因之一。街上很多人都在医疗领域工作，包括弗朗西斯，还有组织每晚噪音聚会的邻居薇薇安（Vivian），以及伊薇特和伊薇特的丈夫。但我认为，这条街上的退休人员每晚坚持这样做还有更深层的原因。
Because we are a very special block, and we watch out for each other. If they don't see I come out at 7:00, they look for me.
因为我们是一个非常特别的街区，我们相互照应。如果他们没看到我7点出来，就会找我。
So is one of the reasons why it's still going on because people are checking on each other?
那么，这还在继续的原因之一是因为人们在互相检查吗？
If I don't come out, this lady comes, that lady comes, the people over there come.
如果我不出来，这位女士会来，那位女士会来，那边的人也会来。
Someone will knock on your door to see how you are?
会有人敲你的门看你怎么样吗？
If I don't come out at 7:00, if I don't pick up my New York Times paper at 6:00 they look for me. They know I'm alone.
如果我7点没出来，如果我6点没去取《纽约时报》，他们就会找我。他们知道我一个人住。
Some nights, do you just feel tired, and you don't want to come out?
有些晚上，你感到累了，不想出来吗？
I have to. I have to. They will come here! [CHUCKLES]
我必须出来。我必须出来。他们会找上门的！[轻笑]
In fact, Ivette and Vivian, who organized all this, do use it to keep an eye out for their neighbors to make sure they're doing OK. And when things quieted down, Ivette ran through her little mental checklist of neighbors for me.
事实上，组织这一切的伊薇特和薇薇安确实利用这个机会留意邻居，确保他们安然无恙。当周围安静下来后，伊薇特为我列出了她心里的邻居清单。
I saw Mastrota. I saw Severina. Paul came out from next door. That's Sugar. Beverly is here. Arlene is the one that I didn't see.
我看到马斯特罗塔了。我看到塞韦里纳（Severina）了。保罗（Paul）从隔壁出来了。那是舒格（Sugar）。贝弗利（Beverly）也在这。阿琳（Arlene）是我没看见的。
One neighbor who Ivette checks on every night is her next-door neighbor Josephine, who got COVID and went to the hospital for a while. She's back at home now, but still bedridden, so she doesn't come outside.
伊薇特每晚都会查看的一位邻居是她的隔壁邻居约瑟芬（Josephine），她得了新冠并住了一阵子院。她现在回家了，但仍卧床不起，所以她没法出来。
Josephine waved to the window, so she's not angry at me today. [CHUCKLES]
约瑟芬朝窗户挥手了，所以她今天没生我的气。[轻笑]
And which window was that?
那是哪扇窗户？
This window right here. It's hard to see. I know because I know what I'm looking for. But I can see her when she waves.
就是这扇窗户。很难看清。我知道是因为我知道我在找什么。但我能看到她挥手。
Oh, she doesn't even raise the drape.
哦，她连窗帘都没拉开。
No, no.
不，不。
You're seeing her through the drape.
你是透过窗帘看到她的。
Right.
没错。
Oh, that's very--
哦，那真是——
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
You really have to know the neighborhood for that.
你确实得非常了解这个街区才能做到。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
It's just starting to get dark. A pretty night. And people hung out on the sidewalk, chatting in front of Monica Lehmann Gonzalez's house. She's a school teacher and the mother of three school kids.
天刚开始黑。美丽的夜晚。人们在人行道上闲逛，在莫妮卡·莱曼·冈萨雷斯（Monica Lehmann Gonzalez）的家门前聊天。她是一名教师，也是三个上学孩子的母亲。
I think the beauty of this is that after all the banging is done, that there's conversations where we just linger, and talk, and kind of catch up. And I think that's so nice.
我觉得这最美妙的地方在于，敲击声结束后，大家会留下来聊天，联络感情。我认为这非常好。
And what will be the sign that the pandemic has gone away enough that you can stop?
那么，什么迹象会表明疫情已经过去，你们可以停下来了？
We have no idea. We really have no idea.
我们不知道。我们真的不知道。
I kind of don't want it to end, though. I don't want it to end.
不过，我倒有点不希望它结束。我不希望它结束。
Now I'm imagining, COVID is going to end, and you guys are just going to be coming out after COVID.
我现在在想，新冠终会结束，而你们这些家伙即便在新冠之后还会继续出来。
I think that's a possibility. I think it's a possibility.
我觉得有可能。我觉得有可能。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
It's the dailiness of the 7:00 get-together, the fact that it happens every single day. That's what's made it mean so much to all of them. They made this part of the day a little life raft that they gathered on during this terrible, dangerous last year that made it like a daily prayer.
是每晚7点聚会的日常性，它每天都发生，这一点让它对他们每个人都意义重大。他们把这一天中的时刻当作在这一年可怕、危险的日子里的一只小救生筏，这让它变得像每天的祈祷一样。
I personally haven't prayed every day since I was a little boy. But somebody who does it as an adult told me that it's the fact that the words and rituals never change day to day that gives comfort. He has days when the prayers mean less to him and days when they mean a lot more. And feeling that difference from day to day also tells him something.
我个人从童年起就没再每天祈祷过。但一位成年后坚持祈祷的人告诉我，正是因为言语和仪式日复一日从未改变，才给予了他慰藉。他有时觉得祈祷对他意义不大，有时觉得意义重大。而这种日复一日的感受差异也给了他某种启示。
Today, we're devoting our program to other things that we do whose dailiness is what is important about them and gives them meaning, helps us see things more clearly. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天，我们将节目致力于那些我们所做的、因其“日常性”而变得重要且赋予意义的事情，它们帮助我们更清晰地看待事物。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, "How Do You Get To Carnegie Hall?" So usually, if we do something every day, like exercise, or floss, or keep a diary, it's because we decide we're going to do it. But other times, it's because the world has chosen for us. This first story is a little bit of both of those. Ben Calhoun tells what happened.
第一幕，“如何去卡内基音乐厅？”通常，如果我们每天做某事，比如锻炼、用牙线清洁或写日记，是因为我们决定要这样做。但有时，是因为世界为我们做了选择。这第一个故事兼具这两者。本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）讲述了发生的事情。
The way this story started, Lindsay was in the middle of changing her whole life around. She'd been living and working in Ireland, but she decided to take a leap. She was going to start a new chapter-- move to the other side of the world.
故事的开始是这样的，琳赛（Lindsay）当时正处在彻底改变自己生活的过程中。她一直住在爱尔兰工作，但她决定放手一搏。她要开启新篇章——搬到地球的另一端。
I had actually just accepted a job, and I was meant to move to Australia in April.
我当时其实刚接受了一份工作，本打算四月份搬到澳大利亚。
Oh, so you were getting ready to leave Dublin. You were on your way out the door.
哦，所以你当时正准备离开都柏林。你正准备出门。
Totally. I was actually almost all the way packed, truly ready to move. And I was dating an Australian guy who had just moved to Australia. And I was meant to follow him a couple weeks later. And then the pandemic hit.
完全是这样。我当时行李几乎都装好了，真心准备搬家。而且我当时正在和一个刚搬到澳大利亚的澳大利亚男生约会。我本打算几周后跟随他而去。然后疫情爆发了。
Lindsay couldn't leave, and she had to scramble to find a place to stay. Eventually, she got an apartment on the south side of Dublin. It was actually this great place-- a one-bedroom in a really pretty row house. It looks like it was pulled out of 101 Dalmatians or something. The place was cozy. It had these pretty bay windows that looked out onto the street and a sunny little breakfast nook in the kitchen-- Not that things were going super great for Lindsay otherwise.
琳赛无法离开，她不得不争分夺秒地寻找住所。最终，她在都柏林南侧租到了一间公寓。那其实是个很棒的地方——一间带真正漂亮排屋的一居室。看起来就像是从《101忠狗》或类似电影里搬出来的一样。那个地方很温馨。它有漂亮的凸窗，可以看到街道，厨房里还有一个阳光明媚的小早餐角——但这并不意味着琳赛的生活在那之后就一帆风顺了。
She and that Australian guy broke up. And her move, her new job, new life-- all that got called off in slow motion. And Lindsay, she was alone in lockdown. She says this was actually one of the more depressing times she remembers. And it was in the middle of all of that that she started to hear music three or four times a day.
她和那个澳大利亚男生分手了。她的搬家、新工作、新生活——这一切都以慢动作告吹。琳赛被独自困在封锁中。她说这是她记忆中最令人沮丧的时光之一。就在这一切之中，她开始每天三四次听到音乐。
I would notice when I was-- I'd be doing the dishes, or I'd be doing something so mundane. And then it would happen. Yeah.
我会注意到当我——我在洗碗时，或者在做些琐事时。然后它就发生了。是的。
The music was coming from nearby. It was a saxophone, somebody practicing, pretty clearly a beginner. But the most notable part of it was the song. It was the same one everyday, again, and again, and again. It was the Pink Panther theme song.
音乐从附近传来。那是一把萨克斯风，有人在练习，很明显是个初学者。但最引人注目的是那首歌。每天都是同一首，一遍又一遍，一遍又一遍。那是《粉红豹》的主题曲。
[SAXOPHONE PLAYING]
[萨克斯风演奏]
What you're hearing is actually the sound of a video montage Lindsay put together. And the funny of this was not lost on her. In the video, you notice the range of time stamps-- morning, afternoon, 10:30 at night, "The Pink Panther Theme" always in the background. You'll hear it as Lindsay eats at her kitchen table or leans against the door frame in her living room, holding back a smile, as she lays on her yoga mat or walks through her hall.
你现在听到的是琳赛制作的视频蒙太奇的声音。其中的滑稽之处琳赛心知肚明。在视频中，你注意到时间戳的跨度——早上、下午、晚上10点半，《粉红豹》主题曲始终在背景中播放。你会听到它伴随着琳赛在餐桌吃东西，或者倚在客厅门框上强忍着笑容，或者躺在瑜伽垫上，或者走在走廊里。
When he picked up the horn, and you first heard the notes come out, you were like, oh, I'm in for how long?
当他拿起萨克斯，你第一次听到音符出来时，你当时的反应是，哦，我要经历多久？
I'd say 45 minutes or an hour.
我会说45分钟到一个小时。
45 minutes to an hour? Wow.
45分钟到一个小时？哇。
Or maybe-- oh, god, now I feel like, is that crazy? Maybe 20 to 30 minutes?
或者也许——天哪，我现在觉得，那是不是疯了？也许20到30分钟？
No, I mean--
不，我是说——
Maybe it was 20 to 30 minutes. It felt, to me, like it was never ending. It felt, to me, by the end, that I was just-- it was all day, all night.
也许是20到30分钟。对我来说，感觉它没完没了。最后给我的感觉是，我只是——整天整夜都是它。
So it became a staple of your existence.
所以它成了你生活的一部分。
Yeah, and it was to the point where I was trying to work during the day. I was trying to get things done. And then I'd be in a meeting, and all my co-workers could hear.
是的，以至于我在白天尝试工作时，我正努力处理事情。然后我正在开会，所有的同事都能听到。
Lindsay was now working remotely from this Dublin apartment. And all the Pink Panther-ing became a running joke for the people that she worked with. It was so audible that Lindsay found herself constantly having to mute during video meetings.
琳赛现在在都柏林这间公寓远程办公。所有的“粉红豹”曲子成了她同事间的一个老梗。声音大到琳赛发现自己在视频会议时不得不不断静音。
Because mics on phones vary so much, I couldn't totally grasp how loud it was in person. How loud was it?
因为手机上的麦克风差别很大，我没法完全体会现场有多大声。到底有多大声？
Oh, it sounded like it was in my house. So when I posted this on Twitter, I got all kinds of responses. But people were wondering if I was playing a recording of it in my house. But it was so loud that it did sound like it was coming from inside the house. And I don't know if he knew how loud it was.
哦，听起来就像在我屋里一样。所以当我把它发到推特上时，我收到了各种各样的回应。但人们想知道我是否在屋里播放它的录音。但它真的太响了，听起来确实像是从屋子里面传出来的。我不知道他是否知道声音有多大。
Yeah.
是的。
And I don't think he did.
我觉得他不知道。
Lindsay says this went on for weeks and weeks, several times every day. Just to point out, most days, this was actually her only real-life human contact-- the saxophone coming through the walls. The video montage that Lindsay made of all this, she eventually tweeted it, and it accumulated 5.4 million views. Just for scale, Miles Davis' Kind of Blue has sold 5 million copies.
琳赛说这种情况持续了几个星期又几个星期，每天好几次。需要指出的是，大多数日子里，这其实是她唯一真实的现实接触——通过墙壁传来的萨克斯声。琳赛制作的所有这一切的视频蒙太奇，她最终发了推文，积累了540万次观看。作为对比，迈尔斯·戴维斯（Miles Davis）的《Kind of Blue》卖出了500万张。
The internet responded like the internet. Some of the 4.7 thousand comments-- "interesting how they got further from nailing it the longer they practiced." "Your neighbor's horrible playing should be a crime." "My condolences." "You'd think that the performance would at least improve over time." Someone chimes in, "Sounds like he's still shite, too." The insurance company Geico responded, "We feel your pain."
互联网的反应正如互联网一贯的表现。在4700条评论中，有些写着：“有意思的是，他们练习得越久，离练好就越远。”“你邻居糟糕的演奏应该被定罪。”“向你表示慰问。”“你本以为表演至少会有所进步。”有人附和道：“听起来他现在还是很烂。”保险公司Geico回应称：“我们感同身受。”
For a long time, Lindsay didn't know who the Pink Panther-er was. So when she'd see people in the halls of her building, it was a little like, is that them? Wait, is that them? Though eventually, her suspicions snagged on this one guy.
很长一段时间里，琳赛不知道那个“粉红豹”演奏者是谁。所以当她在楼道里看到人时，会有点像，是他们吗？等等，是他们吗？尽管最终，她的怀疑锁定了一个人。
I would see this guy outside. He would always do this thing where he would walk outside to drink his coffee in his pajamas. And I had a feeling it was him, but I wasn't sure.
我总会看到这个家伙在外面。他总是会做这件事，穿着睡衣走到外面喝咖啡。我有一种感觉就是他，但我不能确定。
For some reason, I feel like drinking coffee outside in your pajamas is kind of saxophone behavior.
出于某种原因，我觉得穿着睡衣在外面喝咖啡就是一种“萨克斯风行为”。
Yeah, he had a vibe.
是的，他有种气场。
It was a saxophone vibe.
那是一种萨克斯风气场。
He had a saxophone vibe, for sure.
当然有萨克斯风气场。
[MUSIC - "THE PINK PANTHER THEME"]
[音乐 - 《粉红豹主题曲》]
So come with me, if you will, to the other side of Lindsay's wall, to the other end of the saxophone rainbow, where there was a young man named Rajat. At the time, he was 23. Like Lindsay, he was living and working in Ireland. As far as Rajat knew, his only audience was inside his apartment at this window where he would practice.
那么，请随我一起，来到琳赛墙的另一边，来到萨克斯风彩虹的另一端，那里有一位名叫拉贾特（Rajat）的年轻人。那时他23岁。像琳赛一样，他在爱尔兰生活工作。就拉贾特所知，他唯一的观众就在他练习窗户的公寓里。
I had a large window. And on the windowsill, I had three plants, a basil plant-- I just randomly had a potato that was going off, and I put it into a pot, and it started to grow. So that was my potted potato plant. And there was a coriander plant as well.
我有一扇大窗户。在窗台上，我有三盆植物，一盆罗勒——我随手有一个发芽的土豆，我把它种进盆里，它就开始生长了。所以那是我的盆栽土豆植物。还有一盆香菜。
So I would play to them. That's my audience every day. And I still believe that that potted potato plant grew, and it took off. So I think I had something to do with it.
所以我每天都对着它们弹奏。那就是我每天的观众。我至今仍相信那盆土豆植物长得那么高，肯定有我的一份功劳。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
No joke. It was super tall.
没开玩笑。它长得超级高。
Rajat told me, for the record, he had no idea people could hear him like this. He said, some people in the building had remarked on how he was learning the saxophone. But he just figured, this building is old. It's got to have thick walls. Maybe they hear me faintly, off in the distance.
拉贾特告诉我，郑重声明，他根本不知道人们能这样听到他演奏。他说，楼里有些人提到过他在学萨克斯风。但他只是觉得，这栋楼很老。墙一定很厚。也许他们只是隐约听到一点远处的声响。
Lindsay did eventually come over at some point. She introduced herself, and she asked him to stop because she had a migraine. Rajat says Lindsay was super nice.
琳赛最终确实在那次去了他那。她自我介绍，并要求他停下来，因为她偏头痛。拉贾特说琳赛超级好。
Lindsay says Rajat was genuinely surprised and very sweet. For my fellow rom-com fans, I will note that they are not engaged. But the point is, Rajat actually had no idea how loud his saxophone playing was for her until he saw Lindsay's video later.
琳赛说拉贾特真的感到惊讶且非常甜。对于我的浪漫喜剧影迷同好们，我要指出他们并没有订婚。但重点是，拉贾特其实根本不知道他的萨克斯演奏对她来说有多大声，直到后来他看到了琳赛的视频。
When I saw the video, I was like, wow, that's really loud in the house. I did not think it was that loud in her house. Because that was almost how loud it was for me when I was playing. And so when I heard it for the first time from her perspective, I was like, yeah, I would have had a problem as well if I was there.
当我看到视频时，我当时就想，哇，在屋子里真的太响了。我没想到在她屋子里声音有那么大。因为那几乎就是我在演奏时听到的音量。所以当我第一次从她的角度听到时，我当时就想，是的，如果我在那儿，我也会有意见的。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
Rajat felt like, oh, shoot, I did not know I was bothering anyone. He asked Lindsay what would be a good time to play, and he started practicing during his lunch hour, though an hour was barely enough, he told me. Because what was unfolding on Rajat's side of the building was a love story, a budding romance with the alto saxophone that had started just a few months before this.
拉贾特觉得，哦，糟糕，我不知道我打扰了别人。他问琳赛什么时候演奏比较好，然后他开始在午休时间练习，尽管他告诉我，一个小时根本不够。因为在拉贾特那一侧发生的，是一个爱情故事，一种与中音萨克斯风萌芽的浪漫情怀，那是在此之前几个月才开始的。
Turns out, before COVID hit, in December, Rajat was visiting India. He's from Bangalore. And he was visiting old friends. One of these friends lives on a farm. Rajat says his place is just beautiful. So all these friends, they're there, and they're hanging out.
结果是，在疫情爆发前的12月，拉贾特正在访问印度。他来自班加罗尔。他在看望老朋友。其中一个朋友住在农场。拉贾特说他住的地方太美了。所以所有的朋友都在那儿闲逛。
And one of them picked up a saxophone, right? And it was alto sax, this nice, cute little guy. And like, we were all just-- we were working. And he has a little wood shop. Then we were working.
然后其中一个人拿起了萨克斯风，对吧？那是中音萨克斯，这个漂亮可爱的小东西。然后，我们都在——我们都在忙活。他有一个小木工车间。我们当时在干活。
And from the background, I hear someone playing the beginning riff of "Ain't No Sunshine." And I look out, and it's my friend. He's wearing slippers-- flip-flops and shorts-- sweating because the sun is out, even in December in India. And it's like the Pied Piper. There are a few dogs walking behind him, and he's playing the tune. And I was like, yo, that's amazing. What?
从背景里，我听到有人在吹《Ain't No Sunshine》的开头即兴段。我向外看，原来是我的朋友。他穿着拖鞋——人字拖和短裤——满头大汗，因为即便在12月的印度，太阳也很大。他就像穿着魔笛手一样。几只狗跟在他后面，他正吹着那曲子。我就想，哟，太棒了。什么情况？
Rajat's friend was like, hey, you should try it. He was like, OK. Almost immediately, he was able to get a sound out of the horn. So his friend taught him the first line from "Ain't No Sunshine," and Rajat was off and running.
拉贾特的朋友说，嘿，你应该试试。他说，好。几乎立刻，他就能让萨克斯发出声音了。所以他的朋友教了他《Ain't No Sunshine》的第一句，拉贾特就这样开始了。
And I was just off by myself, playing out into the fields. Literally, I would stay for a good-- if not 45, at least 30 minutes or so, I was just constantly drilling, and drilling, and drilling, and drilling, and drilling it. And that was the moment.
我就独自一人，对着田野演奏。真的，我会在那儿待上好一会儿——如果不是45分钟，至少30分钟左右，我只是在不停地练习，练习，练习，练习，练习那一段。那正是那一刻。
I was getting into a flow. And I think, also, with the saxophone, because you keep blowing so much, there's some degree of-- and then you're like-- [GASPS] --and then you blow again. So there's a high degree of when you rapid breathe when you meditate. There's some degree of you getting kind of like, whoa, what's happening? And so I was getting into this flow state with that. And I was like, wow, this is so good.
我进入了心流状态。而且我认为，萨克斯风因为你一直在吹气，某种程度上——然后你是这样——[吸气]——然后你再吹。所以当你冥想时快速呼吸，有很大程度的——某种程度你会觉得，哇，发生了什么？所以我进入了那种心流状态。我就觉得，哇，这真是太好了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Getting that sound to come out of the saxophone right away, did you feel a little bit like, oh, I'm kind of a natural?
让萨克斯风立刻发出那个声音，你有没有感觉，哦，我有点天赋？
For sure, yeah. Yeah, yeah, for sure.
当然，是的。是的，是的，当然。
When he got back to Ireland, he researched carefully. And he bought a saxophone, an alto. And then he set about learning to play it.
当他回到爱尔兰后，他仔细研究了一番。然后他买了一把中音萨克斯。然后他开始学习演奏它。
He made this little notebook for himself. On the first page-- all caps-- he wrote, "CONSISTENCY IS KEY," meaning, practice everyday, a little bit, or a lot. On the second page, he made a list of songs that he wanted to learn, including, of course, "The Pink Panther." Rajat told me this was the song he maybe most identified with the saxophone. And so he found a video tutorial of it online, where a guy walks through the song phrase by phrase.
他为自己做了个小笔记本。在第一页——全大写——他写着，“持之以恒是关键”，意思是，每天练习，一点点或者多一点。在第二页，他列出了想学的歌单，当然包括《粉红豹》。拉贾特告诉我，这可能是他最能与萨克斯风产生共鸣的曲子。所以他在网上找到了一个视频教程，里面有人逐句地讲解这首歌。
And so I would have drilled that video 80-plus times, just hard, just again, and again, and again, and again. And just keep going, keep going, keep going.
所以我把那个视频练习了80遍以上，只是刻苦练习，一遍，又一遍，又一遍，又一遍。一直继续，一直继续，一直继续。
You're like, I'm going to get this into my muscle memory.
你当时就想，我要把它练进肌肉记忆里。
Yeah, exactly. And because it was something I really wanted to get good, because it sounded so cool, the final product at the end of that video, that I was like, I need to get this. And I was not going to move on to anything else until I got this done.
是的，完全正确。而且因为那是我真心想练好的东西，因为它听起来太酷了，视频最后的成品，所以我当时想，我一定要学会它。如果没学会，我绝不会进行下一项。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So at one point in time, it was not in heavy rotation. It was the rotation, you know?
所以一度，它不在轮播列表里。它就是唯一的轮播内容，你知道吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yeah, but I was not getting tired of it. It was entertaining. And it was so nice to see. Because at the end of it as well, there's this beautiful riff. [VOCALIZING]
是的，但我没有感到厌倦。它很有娱乐性。看到它真的很好。因为在曲子最后，有一段优美的即兴段。[哼唱]
And oh, that's so cool! It's so funky when you get it right. So it would give me glimpses. I'd do the first three phases horribly, but I'd say, OK, play to the end. And just the one time-- one time-- if I get the nice little riff properly, I'd get like, oh, this is going so well.
哦，那太酷了！练好后真的很时髦。所以它会给我一些闪光点。我前三个阶段做得一团糟，但我会说，好的，吹到最后。只要那一次——就那一次——如果我能把那段即兴吹好，我会感到，哦，这进行得太顺利了。
The thing I love about the situation is just how different the same song played day in and day out for months could feel in these two neighboring apartments by two people in their own little bubbles, like some kind of musical Rorschach test. For Lindsay, whether it was irritating or funny, it was an artifact of her confinement. But for Rajat, it was the exact opposite. It was an escape.
关于这种情况我最喜欢的一点是，同一首歌日复一日地在两个相邻的公寓里被两个人以自己的小泡泡播放，竟然能产生如此不同的感觉，就像某种音乐版罗夏墨迹测试。对于琳赛来说，无论它是恼人还是滑稽，它都是她禁足生活的产物。但对于拉贾特来说，恰恰相反。这是一种逃避。
Yeah, because there's only so much Netflix you can do until you start feeling sick of doing that. And yeah, so this was genuinely-- I got up. I was like, oh, I'm going to get to practice saxophone today. That got me through, you know?
是的，因为奈飞看多了你就会开始觉得腻了。所以这真的是——我起床了。我就想，哦，我今天可以练萨克斯风了。这帮我撑过了那段时光，你知道吗？
Looking back on this little chapter, for Lindsay's part, she told me, the main consequence of all this has been that, months after leaving that apartment, moving back to the United States, she's still hearing "The Pink Panther Theme" all the time. It's just coming through the walls of her memory now, like a phantom limb, a pink phantom limb. All of this has also stuck with Rajat.
回望这个小篇章，对琳赛而言，她告诉我，这一切的主要后果是，在离开那间公寓几个月、搬回美国后，她仍然一直听到《粉红豹》主题曲。它现在就像一个幻肢，一个粉色的幻肢，穿过她记忆的墙壁传过来。这一切也留在了拉贾特心中。
So believe it or not, but this 5 million view thing has scarred me to a certain extent. Because honestly, I've now moved to Italy, right? I'm staying here.
所以信不信由你，这个500万观看的视频在某种程度上留下了创伤。因为说实话，我现在已经搬到意大利了，对吧？我住在那儿。
And I live in these apartments where you share a courtyard. So I have a balcony right here, and it opens out into this beautiful courtyard. You can see the sky, birds on top. Lovely.
我住的公寓共用一个庭院。我这儿有个阳台，它正对着这个美丽的庭院。你可以看到天空，顶上有鸟。可爱极了。
But there's just everybody around here, and it echoes. So I cannot play the saxophone here because, at least in Dublin, if someone had an issue, I could speak to them and try to diffuse the situation. I cannot do that in Italian. [LAUGHS] I can't.
但周围到处都是人，而且有回声。所以我不能在这儿吹萨克斯，因为至少在都柏林，如果有人有意见，我可以和他们沟通并尝试化解。我没法用意大利语那样做。[笑] 我做不到。
So I actually found a spot in. You know the storage rooms that are super dank, in the cellar? Everything is musty, where they keep the suitcases. I managed to go there once and clear out some space. And I was like, this will be my saxophone room.
所以我其实在地窖里发现了一个地方。你知道地窖里那些超级阴暗的储藏室吗？什么东西都发霉，他们存放行李的地方。我设法去过那里一次，清理出一些空间。我当时就想，这会是我的萨克斯练习室。
Rajat says, though, it's just so out of the way, he hasn't done it. For Rajat, lockdowning in Dublin, he had really been in this bubble where, true or not, he was so convinced no one could hear him. It was like he got to spend swaths of his day singing in the shower, dancing like no one was watching, loving "The Pink Panther Theme" like he'd never been hurt, if you know what I mean.
不过拉贾特说，因为那太偏僻了，他还没去过。对于在都柏林封锁期间的拉贾特来说，他真的处于一个泡泡里，不管真假，他深信没人能听到他。就像他可以在淋浴时唱歌，像没人看着那样跳舞，像从未受过伤一样热爱《粉红豹》主题曲，如果你明白我的意思。
That became his everyday. And since then, well, he's been a little unsure how to get back to that spot where he can play and feel quite so free. He's been chasing that feeling. Aren't we all?
那成了他的日常。从那以后，好吧，他有点不知道怎么回到那个可以演奏并感到如此自由的境地了。他一直在追逐那种感觉。我们不都是这样吗？
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Ben Calhoun is one of the producers of our show.
本·卡尔霍恩是我们节目的制片人之一。
Act Two, "So Nice to Hear Your Voice." We now turn to somebody who had one daily routine that changed to a different daily routine. And I don't want to get ahead of the story too much but just to say what a vast effect it had on her and how quickly those effects kicked in.
第二幕，“听到你的声音真好。”我们现在转向另一位有每日例行公事并转变为另一种例行公事的人。我不打算剧透太多故事，只想说这对她产生了多么巨大的影响，以及这些影响生效得多么迅速。
The person with the daily routine in the story is Dee Brown. She moved into long-term care five years ago. And for four years, somebody would visit her everyday. Family or her best friend would come nearly everyday. They'd go out to eat, go on long drives into the mountains.
这个故事里有每日例行公事的人是迪·布朗（Dee Brown）。她五年前搬进了长期护理机构。四年来，每天都有人来看她。家人或她最好的朋友几乎每天都会来。他们会出去吃饭，去山上做长途驾驶。
Then COVID hit. And the facilities she was in, following national guidelines, didn't allow anybody to have any visitors. Communal dining and group activities were also cancelled.
然后新冠爆发了。她所在的机构遵循国家指导方针，不允许任何人探视。社区用餐和集体活动也都被取消了。
So Dee's family invented a new routine-- daily phone calls. Basically, they had made a schedule for everybody in the family to phone. And that way, Dee would get calls every single day.
于是迪的家人发明了一种新的日常——每日电话。基本上，他们为家里每个人安排了一个打电话的日程表。这样，迪每天都能接到电话。
They would chat. They would socialize. They would try to keep her spirits up, try to keep her from getting bored. Dee's granddaughter Cecilia Brown was one of the callers, phoning once a week or so. And she put together this story.
他们会聊天。他们会社交。他们努力让她保持精神振作，尽量不让她感到无聊。迪的孙女塞西莉亚·布朗（Cecilia Brown）是打电话的人之一，大约每周打一次。她整理了这个故事。
When my family started this, we figured naively, we'd do this for a few weeks, maybe a month, until things got back to normal. And the calls were fun.
当我家人开始这样做时，我们天真地以为，我们会这样做几周，也许一个月，直到一切恢复正常。这些电话很有趣。
Hello? Dee? Can you hear me?
喂？迪？你能听到我吗？
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
My first call, March 27, we were still getting used to the phone.
我的第一次通话，3月27日，我们还在适应电话。
Dee, I think you put me on hold.
迪，我想你把我设为保持通话了。
But Dee was pretty happy. She'd start most calls by telling me about how nice her apartment was. She took her calls from her favorite lounge chair.
但迪很高兴。她大部分电话开始时都会告诉我她的公寓有多好。她是在她最喜欢的躺椅上接电话的。
Hello?
喂？
Oh, that was weird.
哦，那太怪了。
Cecilia, yeah, hello. How are you doing?
塞西莉亚，是的，喂。你最近好吗？
I'm good. I'm good.
我很好。我很好。
Yeah, what's up?
是啊，怎么了？
Dee loved to say the unexpected thing, make fun of herself if it meant making other people laugh.
迪喜欢说些意想不到的话，如果能让别人笑出来，她不介意拿自己开玩笑。
Oh, I have a real problem right now. I got some underwear, the kind that stretches, only it's too tight. And I sit down and they go, ugh, my stomach. [LAUGHS] Those are big problems, right?
哦，我现在有个真正的问题。我买了一些内衣，那种有弹性的，结果太紧了。我一坐下来它们就说，额，我的肚子。[笑] 这些都是大问题，对吧？
Yeah, I have that problem, too.
是的，我也有那个问题。
Yeah, well, you just think of me as you're trying to pull your underwear down so it makes you feel very graceful.
是的，好吧，当你试图把内衣往下拉时，就把我当成你，这样你会觉得很优雅。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Growing up, Dee wasn't what I thought of as a typical grandma. For one thing, we call her Dee, not grandma. She also dressed like an old Colorado hippie-- tons of turquoise jewelry and tie dye. She always smelled like coffee, which she drank all day, even at midnight.
成长过程中，迪不是我想象中那种典型的奶奶。首先，我们叫她迪，而不是奶奶。她的装扮也像老科罗拉多嬉皮士——戴着一堆绿松石首饰，穿扎染衣服。她身上总有咖啡味，她整天喝咖啡，哪怕半夜也喝。
She never did the normal grandma stuff with my sister and me, like take us out for ice cream or whatever. Dee was a talker, so that's what we'd do-- sit in the backyard and talk for hours. It didn't matter how old you were.
她从不和我和妹妹做那种普通的奶奶做的事，比如带我们出去吃冰淇淋之类的。迪是个健谈的人，所以那就是我们会做的——坐在后院聊上几个小时。不管你多大。
And she was funny. Though my dad said she'd sometimes disguise something as a joke, just to get what she wanted. In her 40's, after raising three kids and getting a divorce, she ended up in AA. It became a huge part of her life, so much so she ended up sponsoring over 100 people. She'd still go to meetings a few times a week. Now, of course, all that was gone.
而且她很幽默。虽然我爸说她有时会把真心话伪装成笑话，只为了达成目的。40多岁时，在抚养三个孩子并离婚后，她最终参加了匿名戒酒会（AA）。这成了她生命中很大的一部分，以至于她最终资助了100多人。她每周还会去开几次会。现在，当然，这一切都没了。
Yeah, it's been kind of a boring day because I haven't been able to go to the store and call my friend who has my car.
是啊，今天有点无聊，因为我没法去商店，也不能给那个帮我存车的朋友打电话。
Yeah. Can you walk in the hallways?
是啊。你能在走廊里走吗？
Yeah. Yeah, I walk through the hallways, and everybody else is walking in the hallway, too, you know? Because they're just trying to get a little exercise.
是的。是的，我在走廊里走，其他人也在走廊里走，你知道吗？因为他们只是想稍微锻炼一下。
But this will pass. And we'll be OK. It's not going to kill me, sitting in here instead of going out and walking around.
但这都会过去的。我们会没事的。这杀不死我，只是坐在这里而不是出去散步。
I taped these calls with her permission. Dee was going on 88. I'd done the same thing with my other grandmother when she hit her late 80's. It was just something to capture a little bit of their lives on tape while I still had them.
我在她的允许下录了这些电话。迪快88岁了。我在另一位奶奶快80岁时也做过同样的事。这只是为了在她们还在的时候，录下一点她们的生活。
Dee had dementia, but it was pretty mild. She'd forget small things like where I lived, tell me stories she told me before. But she was still pretty with it.
迪患有痴呆症，但程度很轻。她会忘记小事，比如我住哪里，跟我讲她讲过的故事。但她思路还算清晰。
This was another reason for the frequent calls. Isolation is really bad for anyone with dementia. You've probably heard people say the brain is like a muscle. You need to use it to maintain it.
这也是频繁打电话的另一个原因。隔离对任何痴呆症患者来说都很糟糕。你可能听人说过大脑就像肌肉。你需要使用它来维持它。
With dementia, this is especially true. The more you use your mind, use words, the more those things stick with you. But when you're isolated, you stop practicing. Your mind starts to slip away. And once it goes, it usually doesn't come back.
对于痴呆症，尤其如此。你越使用大脑，使用词汇，那些东西就越会保留在你身上。但当你被隔离时，你就停止了练习。你的思维开始衰退。一旦它走了，通常就不会再回来了。
In those first calls, I didn't worry too much about that with Dee. She had worked as a therapist for decades and would still kind of do informal therapy on everyone, including me. Without my asking, she'd just start working out my options with me on the phone.
在最初的几次通话中，我没太担心迪的情况。她做过几十年的治疗师，仍然会以某种方式对每个人进行非正式的心理辅导，包括我。没等我要求，她就开始在电话里帮我理清选择。
OK, what you do is, you get a big piece of paper, and you write down every one of them that you'd like to do. What do I want? What do I not want?
好的，你该做的是，找一张大纸，写下所有你愿意做的事情。我想要什么？我不想要什么？
I'd just finished grad school and wasn't really sure what to do with my life.
我刚研究生毕业，真的不知道拿我的人生怎么办。
See if you can find where you want to be and what you want to do when you grow up. I hate that one.
看看你能找到你想在哪里，以及当你长大后想做什么。我讨厌那个词。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It's fun. That make sense?
这很有趣。说得通吗？
Just like that. Yeah. Yeah, I just have to just figure out what I want.
就像那样。是的。是的，我只需要找出我想要什么。
Yeah, what do you want? You find out what you want to, and then you keep in touch. Because I love talking to you.
是啊，你想要什么？你找出你想要的东西，然后保持联络。因为我喜欢和你说话。
I love talking to you too.
我也喜欢和你说话。
When I called her the next week, April 5, she was still joking about things. But 11 days after that, my third call with her, she seemed much worse. She'd always liked her apartment before, but now I got the feeling it was starting to feel oppressive.
下周，4月5日，我给她打电话时，她还在开玩笑。但11天后，我和她的第三次通话，她看起来糟糕多了。她以前一直喜欢她的公寓，但现在我觉得那种压抑感开始显现了。
I mean, we've got some sunshine today.
我是说，今天阳光不错。
Uh, I guess we-- we didn't get sunshine. Well, maybe a little. Oh, it's that little dribble through that little crack in the window. It's just a little tiny crack of light, not much to pay attention to.
呃，我想我们——我们没得到阳光。好吧，也许有一点。哦，那是透过窗户缝透进来的一点点光。那只是一小道光，不值得注意。
And my mouth is so dry. And the air is so dry. And my whole body is going, ugh. I'm just antsy, awful. I'm really just stuck here, it seems like.
我的嘴太干了。空气也太干了。我整个身体都在说，额。我只是坐立不安，糟透了。我似乎真的被困在这里了。
Two weeks after that call, Dee started needing round-the-clock care. And by May, it was clear to me parts of Dee were drifting away. Things she'd explained to me weeks ago no longer made any sense to her, like they were swirling together in her head, and I had to explain them back to her.
那次通话两周后，迪开始需要24小时照护。到五月，我清楚地感觉到迪的一部分正在漂离。几周前她向我解释过的事情对她来说已毫无意义，就像在她脑海里搅成了一团，我不得不反过来解释给她听。
I'm trying to find out where my mind went sideways or something. I know where I am. It's just nothing anybody's saying is making any sense.
我想找出我的思想是从哪里出了偏差。我知道我在哪里。只是别人说的话都没什么意义。
And I can see some people walking along. And they're going up and down. And I don't know who's what or why.
我可以看见有些人走来走去。他们走上走下。我不知道谁是谁，为什么。
Yeah. Yeah, I mean, I think one of the things that is happening is that, because people are stuck in their apartments, they're walking up and down the hallway because it's the only place they can go to get exercise.
是啊。是啊，我是说，我觉得发生的一件事是，因为人们被困在公寓里，他们会在走廊走上走下，因为那是他们唯一能去锻炼的地方。
Yeah.
是的。
I think that's probably what's happening. That's why it seems so weird.
我想那可能就是正在发生的事。这就是为什么它看起来那么奇怪。
It does. Everything feels weird. And I don't know. I'm just going to try and get some orientation or something.
是的。一切都感觉很奇怪。我不知道。我只是试图找回方向什么的。
Hm.
嗯。
And I have a television thing up in front of me, but it doesn't make any sense.
我面前有一个电视，但它没什么意义。
Hm. What do you mean? Like the things that people are saying doesn't make sense?
嗯。你是什么意思？就像人们说的话没意义？
Yeah, the people in there. And I don't know. It just seems like I'm in a strange world. But I will work on it.
是的，里面的人。我不知道。这就像我处在一个奇怪的世界里。但我会努力解决的。
Yeah. Yeah.
是啊。是啊。
I will work on it-- that's so Dee, always sure there's a way to fix things if you just organized your thoughts correctly, even if the things she's trying to organize is her own dementia. I hated that she had to work this out alone, so I tried to work on it too. But I was kind of grasping at how to help.
我会努力解决的——这太像迪了，总是坚信只要理清思路就能解决问题，即便她试图组织的东西是她自己的痴呆症。我恨她不得不独自面对这一切，所以我试图帮她。但我有点不知如何下手。
OK, well, let's talk about something that might feel grounding. Why don't we talk about when you were living in Kansas City?
好的，我们谈谈一些可能让你感到踏实的事情吧。我们谈谈你住在堪萨斯城的时候好吗？
Oh, boy, that goes way back.
哦，孩子，那太久远了。
Yeah, will you tell me about your house in Kansas City?
是啊，你能跟我讲讲你在堪萨斯城的房子吗？
Oh, I don't know if I can remember much about it. Oh, god, I just really feel like I don't know what they're expecting of me here. I don't know. I'm just off-center. That's all there is to it.
哦，我不知道我还记不记得多少。哦，天哪，我真觉得我不知道他们在这里对我有什么期望。我不知道。我只是偏离了中心。这就是全部。
It was so hard to comfort her. And it wasn't just her confusion. It was also that, the worse she got, the more physically uncomfortable she got too. There were basic things she needed that would have been so easy to do in person, but not over the phone.
安慰她太难了。不仅仅是她的困惑。也是因为，她状况越糟，身体就越难受。她需要一些基本的东西，如果面对面，这些事做起来很容易，但在电话里不行。
My mouth is so dry that if I try and move my lips, it's just hurtful.
我的嘴太干了，如果我试图动动嘴唇，那真的很痛。
It hurts?
很痛吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah. What about water? Do you have some water you could have a sip of?
是啊。水呢？你有能喝一口的水吗？
I have some water right here. I've gotten a sip of water, but-- oh. Now I can't get any water through the straw. Huh. I can't get any water to come through this straw. Oh, boy.
我这儿有水。我喝了一口水，但是——哦。现在我没法通过吸管喝水了。哈。我没法通过这吸管喝到水。哦，天哪。
Are you sucking?
你在吸吗？
Yeah, trying to. Mm, mm! [GULPING] Finally got a little water.
是啊，在试。嗯，嗯！[大口吞咽声]终于喝到一点水了。
Around this time, my family started talking about Dee's progression. Even though it should have been obvious to me what was happening, I didn't want to believe it. When I talked to my sister, we'd make excuses for Dee, say she was just having a bad day, or that it was her medication, which was always changing. We wanted to believe the old Dee would come back. My dad didn't think she would.
大约在这个时候，我的家人开始讨论迪的进展。尽管对我来说这应该是显而易见的，但我不想相信。当我和我妹妹交谈时，我们会为迪找借口，说她只是今天状态不好，或者是因为她的药物，那些药物一直在变。我们想相信以前的迪会回来。但我爸觉得不会。
By a few months into the pandemic, the toll of isolation on people with dementia was clear. Medical examiners started listing social isolation related to COVID-19 restrictions as a cause of death for people in long-term care centers. Someone from the Alzheimer's Association told me people with dementia have been wandering more, that maybe they're looking for the people who no longer visit. Dee started doing this, too, opening people's doors in the middle of the night.
疫情几个月后，隔离对痴呆症患者的损害很明显了。法医开始将与新冠限制相关的社交隔离列为长期护理中心患者的死因。阿尔茨海默病协会的人告诉我，痴呆症患者四处游荡的情况增加了，也许他们在寻找那些不再来看他们的人。迪也开始这样做了，半夜打开别人的门。
Hello?
喂？
June 2020, just three months into lockdown.
2020年6月，封锁仅三个月。
Hello? Can you hear me?
喂？你能听到我吗？
And who am I talking to?
我在和谁说话？
It's Cecilia.
我是塞西莉亚。
What?
什么？
Cecilia.
塞西莉亚。
I'm sorry, who?
抱歉，谁？
It's Cecilia.
是塞西莉亚。
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
Yeah, your granddaughter.
是啊，你的孙女。
Uh-huh. Oh, and she's-- she's off somewhere, right?
嗯——哦，而且她——她去哪儿了，对吧？
I thought a lot about whether it's OK to play these recordings on the radio. Talked about it with my family. Back when she was with it, Dee knew I might make a story out of these calls, and knew she had dementia, and was game to record. And I'm sure she'd want me to tell the true version of her story. That's Dee. By June, COVID death rates were starting to dip, and people were starting to meet up outside, emerge in small ways. Dee, though, felt almost completely out of reach.
我想了很多关于在广播里播放这些录音是否合适。我和家人讨论过。当她还清醒时，迪知道我可能会把这些通话写成故事，知道她有痴呆症，并乐意录音。我相信她会希望我讲述她真实的生命故事。那就是迪。到了六月，新冠死亡率开始下降，人们开始在户外会面，以小规模出现。迪，虽然，感觉几乎完全无法触及。
What would you like to know that I might know?
你想知道些什么，也许我可能知道的？
Oh, nothing. I just wanted to talk to you.
哦，没什么。我只是想跟你聊聊。
I don't have any idea what's going on.
我不知道现在发生了什么。
Yeah.
是啊。
Oh. Oh. Ugh!
哦。哦。额！
What happened?
发生了什么？
What?
什么？
What happened?
发生了什么？
Oh, I tried to swallow things and look at things, and I don't know what I'm doing. Because everything's in the dark.
哦，我试着吞东西，看着东西，但我不知道我在做什么。因为一切都在黑暗中。
Oh.
哦。
And it's all kind of pitch dark.
而且一切都像是漆黑一片。
Are you having trouble seeing?
你看不清了吗？
I'm sorry. I'm having awful hard trouble talking.
抱歉。我说话真的非常困难。
Oh, it's OK. It's OK. Why don't I call back later, OK?
哦，没关系。没关系。为什么我稍后再打回来，好吗？
Well, I'm trying. Oh, I don't know what I'm doing here. I absolutely don't know what I'm doing.
好吧，我在努力。哦，我不知道我在这儿做什么。我绝对不知道我在做什么。
OK.
好的。
So am I sounding silly?
所以我听起来很傻吗？
No, you don't sound silly. You don't sound silly. It sounds like you're having a tough day.
不，你不傻。你不傻。听起来你只是今天状态不太好。
Ah.
啊。
So you can just put the phone down, and then it'll be over. And I'll say goodbye, OK?
所以你可以把电话放下，然后就结束了。我会说再见的，好吗？
OK.
好的。
OK, I love you, Dee.
好的，我爱你，迪。
I mean, I taste OK. OK, I'll put it down.
我是说，我味道还好。好的，我会放下的。
OK, I love you.
好的，我爱你。
Oh, it's on. It's sitting on the table. Ow. Ow. Ow.
哦，它在上面。它正放在桌子上。哎哟。哎哟。哎哟。
I hung up-- I was standing alone on the street-- and cried. I decided to stop recording all my calls with Dee after this. She was changing so quickly. I just wasn't sure it felt right anymore.
我挂了电话——我独自站在街上——哭了。我决定在这之后停止录下我和迪的所有通话。她变化太快了。我只是不再确定这是否妥当。
And I also, around this time, began to wonder if my calls were doing her any good at all, or if I was just calling to try to convince myself I was helping. I could tell from talking to her that my calls were making her more disoriented, more agitated. Everyone in my family felt that. To be honest, the calls were also pretty painful. So I started calling less and then stopped altogether.
同时，在这个时候，我开始怀疑我的通话是否真的对她有任何帮助，或者我只是为了说服自己在帮忙而打电话。通过和她交谈，我可以感觉到我的通话让她变得更加迷失方向，更加不安。我家人都有这种感觉。说实话，这些电话也很痛苦。所以我开始减少通话，然后完全停止了。
The Alzheimer's Association found that 46,000 more people died from dementia this past year than on average in each of the last five years. They call these excess deaths, people who might not have died if it had been a normal year. We could have predicted this.
阿尔茨海默病协会发现，去年因痴呆症死亡的人数比过去五年平均每年多出46000人。他们称这些为超额死亡，如果那是一个正常的年份，这些人可能不会死。我们本可以预测到这一点。
We've known for years that isolation can lead people living with dementia to rapid deterioration and death. And we isolated them anyway. Another term that's been used is collateral deaths-- people who didn't die directly from COVID, but as a byproduct of it. I hate those terms-- excess death, collateral death, like these deaths somehow fall outside the bounds of the deaths we care about.
多年来，我们一直知道隔离会导致痴呆症患者迅速恶化并死亡。但我们还是隔离了他们。另一个使用的词是间接死亡——不是直接死于新冠的人，而是作为其副产品而死的人。我讨厌这些词——超额死亡，间接死亡，好像这些死亡不知何故落在了我们关心的死亡范围之外。
Eventually, in September, the Centers for Medicare and Medicaid Services reversed their guidelines to allow in visitors in cases where people really needed them, for people who were having trouble eating or drinking and people in emotional distress, people like Dee. I think it would have helped her. I think her dementia wouldn't have progressed so fast, that she wouldn't have gone from where she was in the spring to where she got to by summer in just three months if she weren't so isolated. My whole family thinks so. These nurses think so, too.
最终，在九月，医疗保险和医疗补助服务中心撤销了限制，允许在人们真正需要时探视，比如那些进食或饮水困难的人，以及陷入情绪困扰的人，像迪这样的人。我认为这会对她有帮助。我认为她的痴呆症不会恶化得这么快，如果她不被隔离，她在短短三个月内就不会从春天时的状态变成夏天的样子。我全家都这么认为。护士们也这么认为。
But that change in guidelines came too late for her. Dee died just a few weeks before it, on August 18. She died alone. I ended up deciding to record one last call with Dee in late July, a couple of weeks before she died. It was the last time we ever spoke.
但指导方针的改变对她来说太晚了。迪在它生效前几周就去世了，8月18日。她死时独自一人。我最终决定在7月下旬，她去世前几周，记录下与迪的最后一次通话。那是我们最后一次交谈。
Yeah, OK.
是啊，好的。
Yeah, and so what is it that you're trying to do?
是啊，那你正在试图做什么？
Oh, it's Cecilia, your granddaughter. I'm calling to say hi.
哦，我是塞西莉亚，你的孙女。我打电话来问声好。
Oh, oh, OK. Okey-doke.
哦，哦，好的。好的。
It's good to hear you.
听到你的声音真好。
Well, it's good to be here. Yeah.
好吧，能在这儿真好。是啊。
Yeah.
是啊。
That's good.
那很好。
Mm-hmm.
嗯嗯。
Yeah, I have to--
是啊，我得——
Hm?
嗯？
I have to sort of walk outside here and see what the temperature is.
我得走出去看看温度是多少。
OK, so you have to hang up the phone?
好的，所以你得挂电话了？
Yeah.
是的。
OK. All right, well, I love you, Dee.
好的。好吧，好吧，我爱你，迪。
OK.
好的。
Love you.
爱你。
Bye.
再见。
Talk to you later. Bye.
回头聊。再见。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Cecilia Brown. She's a documentary filmmaker in Portland, Oregon. Coming up, a vast theater with a daily show, but there's a catch. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues
塞西莉亚·布朗。她是俄勒冈州波特兰的一位纪录片制片人。接下来的节目，一个拥有每日演出的巨大剧场，但有个前提。离节目继续还有一分钟，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show, "The Daily," stories about the things that we do every single day and how their "everydayness" is what's important about them and can reveal things that we might not notice otherwise. We have arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, "It Had to be YouTube."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目《每日》，讲述我们每天做的那些事，以及它们的“日常性”为何重要，并揭示了我们否则可能不会注意到的事物。我们已经进入了节目的第三幕。第三幕，“非YouTube不可。”
So Johnny Dark is somebody with a very specific, very unusual, labor intensive practice that he does everyday, more or less. Each day, he shoots and posts a video on YouTube. Kelefa Sanneh writes a lot about music and about other things for The New Yorker and watched a bunch of them.
所以，约翰尼·达克（Johnny Dark）是一个有着非常具体、非常不寻常、劳动密集型习惯的人，他每天都会进行这种练习，或多或少。每一天，他都会拍摄并发布一段视频到YouTube上。凯莱法·桑内（Kelefa Sanneh）为《纽约客》撰写大量关于音乐和其他事物的文章，他观看了其中的许多内容。
The first thing I noticed about Johnny Dark's YouTube page is that it goes on forever, an endless scrolling grid of thumbnail images, the same face, row after row, an older guy with an unnaturally brown pompadour. There are hundreds and hundreds of videos, going back more than five years. Each one is Johnny Dark singing a song.
我注意到约翰尼·达克YouTube页面的第一件事就是它没完没了，一个无尽滚动网格的缩略图，同一张脸，一行接一行，一个留着不自然棕色蓬巴杜发型的老家伙。有成百上千个视频，追溯到五年多前。每一个都是约翰尼·达克在唱歌。
And for all that work, all that music, there's no one watching. You can see it in the view counts-- 10 views, 23 views, seven views. I almost felt guilty clicking on them, like, by increasing the numbers, I was spoiling this pristine place, leaving footprints in practically unfootprinted terrain.
而对于所有这些工作，所有这些音乐，没有人观看。你可以从观看次数中看出来——10次、23次、7次。点击它们时我几乎感到内疚，就像通过增加这些数字，我在破坏这个原始的地方，在几乎未被踏足的土地上留下了足迹。
I only ended up there because an old friend of Johnny's told me about it. He knew I had a taste for stubborn visionaries, for bodies of work that defy easy explanation. There's a simple formula to each video. Johnny Dark is all by himself, no instruments, nothing to sing along with, looking into the camera, dressed in a tuxedo, smiling, as if he were working a casino or a cruise ship, except he's standing in what might be a living room, though it might also be an antique shop. It's full of framed pictures and little statues. Often he's singing a classic, maybe a Sinatra song.
我最终到那儿只是因为约翰尼的一位老朋友告诉了我。他知道我喜欢顽固的远见卓识者，喜欢那种难以轻易解释的作品集。每个视频都有一个简单的公式。约翰尼·达克独自一人，没有乐器，没有伴奏，注视着摄像机，穿着燕尾服，微笑，好像他在赌场或游轮上工作，但他却站在一个看起来可能是客厅的地方，尽管那也可能是个古董店。它摆满了带框的照片和小雕像。他经常唱经典歌曲，也许是弗兰克·辛纳屈（Sinatra）的歌。
(SINGING) I've got the world on a string, sitting on a rainbow. I've got the string around my finger. What a world. What a life. I'm in love.
(歌唱) 我掌握着世界的弦，坐在彩虹上。我的手指绕着这根弦。多么世界。多么生命。我坠入爱河。
Sometimes he'll do something that swings, like "Mack the Knife," but it's a lot of ballads. Hank Williams.
有时他会做一些摇摆的曲子，比如《刀锋麦克》（Mack the Knife），但大多数是民谣。汉克·威廉姆斯（Hank Williams）。
(SINGING) Did you hear that lonesome whippoorwill?
(歌唱) 你听到那孤独的夜鹰了吗？
He went through a Carpenters phase.
他经历过一个“木匠兄妹”（Carpenters）时期。
(SINGING) Why do birds suddenly appear--
(歌唱) 为什么鸟儿突然出现——
In the most recent videos, he's not wearing a tuxedo anymore. It's even more surreal. Now he's tightly framed in a shadowy room, a floating head singing into a mirror, still smiling, but now his smile seems kind of intense.
在最新的视频中，他不再穿燕尾服了。甚至更加超现实。现在他被严密地框在阴暗的房间里，一个漂浮的头对着镜子歌唱，依然微笑着，但现在他的微笑看起来有点紧张。
And he's dressed in dark colors, often black. You can see his hands in black gloves, holding the iPhone that's recording the video. The scene looks less like a cruise ship and more like a seance, which makes the song sound that much spookier, especially the sad ones.
他穿着深色衣服，通常是黑色。你可以看到他戴着黑色手套的手，拿着录制视频的iPhone。这个场景看起来不像是在游轮上，更像是在招魂，这让那首歌听起来更诡异，尤其是那些悲伤的曲子。
(SINGING) If a picture paints a thousand words, then why can't I paint you?
(歌唱) 如果画能描绘千言万语，那么为什么我画不出你？
The whole project seemed obsessive and haunted, as if some club had shut down in the 1970s, but the performance had kept going. Who was this for? Why do this? Why wake up every morning, get dressed, do your hair, and send another video out into the world, out into the void?
整个项目看起来既执着又诡异，好像某个俱乐部在70年代就倒闭了，但表演还在继续。这是给谁看的？为什么要这么做？为什么要每天早上醒来，穿好衣服，梳好头发，把另一段视频传到世界上，传到虚无中？
So I called him up. And I was nervous, to be honest. The videos seemed so compulsive, they made me wonder about his state of mind. But he was friendly, happy to explain.
所以我给他打了电话。说实话，我很紧张。这些视频看起来太像强迫行为了，让我怀疑他的精神状态。但他很友好，很高兴解释。
What is that room that you're in, in those videos?
你视频里的那个房间是什么？
That's actually my living room.
那其实是我的客厅。
OK. And there's all these statues and things.
好的。那儿有很多雕像之类的东西。
Yeah, statues and stuff. That's sort of what I like, you know? Nothing is real expensive.
是的，雕像之类的。那是我喜欢的，你知道吗？没什么真正昂贵的。
It looks expensive.
看起来很贵。
Yeah, it does. It does. I always modeled my place after Buckingham Palace.
是的，确实。确实。我总是按照白金汉宫的样子布置我的地方。
You were dressed, what, in a tuxedo?
你穿的是，什么，燕尾服？
Yeah, the tuxedo was just a way of giving respect to what I thought the older folks would like to see. It's like wearing a tuxedo, working in Las Vegas, when you're opening for Tom Jones. It was just a way of giving respect.
是的，燕尾服只是为了向我认为老人家喜欢看的东西致敬。就像在拉斯维加斯做开场，给汤姆·琼斯（Tom Jones）暖场时穿燕尾服一样。那只是致敬的方式。
Johnny Dark has never actually opened for Tom Jones, the hit-making hunk who sang "It's Not Unusual." But he has worked with lots of other legendary acts. Long before he was singing on YouTube, Johnny Dark was performing for real audiences on stage and on TV, a busy actor and comedian. And so watching those videos, it's kind of like being visited by the ghost of showbusiness past, specifically Johnny's showbusiness past. He kept dropping all these names, household names, many of which weren't quite as household as they used to be.
约翰尼·达克从未真正给汤姆·琼斯暖过场，那位唱《It's Not Unusual》的当红歌手。但他与许多其他传奇人物合作过。在他YouTube唱歌很久之前，约翰尼·达克就真正在舞台上和电视上为观众表演过，是一位忙碌的演员和喜剧演员。所以看那些视频，就像被演艺界的幽灵造访了一样，特别是约翰尼曾经的演艺界。他不断抛出所有这些名字，家喻户晓的名字，其中许多名字不如过去那么家喻户晓了。
Tony Bennett--
托尼·班内特（Tony Bennett）——
In the course of a two-hour conversation, he told me about shining Tony Bennett's shoes in Wildwood, New Jersey, being best friends with Fabian, the '50s heartthrob.
在两个小时的交谈中，他告诉我他在新泽西州怀尔德伍德擦托尼·班内特的鞋子，与50年代万人迷法比安（Fabian）是最好的朋友。
My best friend Fabian.
我最好的朋友法比安。
He toured with Ginger Rogers and also with the Righteous Brothers. At one point, he found himself up against Michael Keaton. They were both competing for a spot on Donnie and Marie Osmond's variety show.
他与琴吉·罗杰斯（Ginger Rogers）一起巡演，也与正义兄弟（Righteous Brothers）一起巡演。一度，他发现自己不得不与迈克尔·基顿（Michael Keaton）竞争。他们都在竞争唐尼和玛丽·奥斯蒙德（Donnie and Marie Osmond）综艺节目的位置。
And I got the Donnie and Marie show! And I don't know whatever happened to Michael Keaton.
我得到了唐尼和玛丽的节目！我不知道迈克尔·基顿后来怎么了。
A spot on a variety show, that was kind of the perfect gig for a guy like Johnny Dark. He's an entertainer, which is the job that maybe doesn't even exist anymore. It means you get up in front of an audience and do whatever it takes to keep them happy-- songs, jokes, skits, dancing, impressions. Here he is on TV in the 1970s.
综艺节目的位置，那对约翰尼·达克这样的家伙来说是完美的演出。他是一个艺人，这种工作也许已经不存在了。这意味着你站在观众面前，不惜一切代价让他们高兴——歌曲、笑话、短剧、舞蹈、模仿。这是他在70年代电视上的样子。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Ladies and gentlemen, I'd like you give me my impression of a rodeo auctioneer. Imagine this guy coming home to his wife at night. Hi, honey, how about a kiss? Another kiss.
女士们先生们，我想给你们表演一段牛仔拍卖员的模仿。想象一下这个家伙晚上回家见妻子。嗨，亲爱的，吻一个怎么样？再吻一个。
Make that three kisses on the right cheek by the little lady with the checkered apron. What's for dinner? I said, what's for dinner? I hear hot dogs.
让那个系着格子围裙的小女士在右脸颊吻三下。晚饭吃什么？我说，晚饭吃什么？我听到热狗。
I hear hot dogs and beans. Do I hear baked beans or lima beans? I hear baked beans. Make that baked beans and butter. Make that Boston baked beans and butter. Do I hear bread? I hear brown bread.
我听到热狗和豆子。我听到烘豆还是利马豆？我听到烘豆。让那是烘豆和黄油。让那是波士顿烘豆和黄油。我听到面包吗？我听到棕色面包。
But by this point, in the 1970s, entertainers in tuxedos were going extinct. And Johnny Dark had that old school style, even though his career really began in a club where a new sensibility was emerging-- the Comedy Store in LA. The regulars there were not all purpose old school entertainers. They were performers with a point of view, unpredictable stand-up comics like Richard Pryor, Robin Williams, Andy Kaufman, but also a young David Letterman and Jay Leno. Johnny Dark got a job there as an MC, introducing the comics. He'd open with a song. And eventually, he started telling jokes, too.
但到了70年代这个点，穿燕尾服的艺人正在灭绝。约翰尼·达克有那种老派风格，尽管他的职业生涯真正始于一个新兴感性出现的俱乐部——洛杉矶的喜剧商店（Comedy Store）。那里的常客并非都是全能的老派艺人。他们是有观点的表演者，不可预测的单口喜剧演员如理查德·普赖尔（Richard Pryor）、罗宾·威廉斯（Robin Williams）、安迪·考夫曼（Andy Kaufman），还有年轻的大卫·莱特曼（David Letterman）和杰·雷诺（Jay Leno）。约翰尼·达克在那里找到了一份主持的工作，介绍喜剧演员。他会以一首歌开场。最终，他也开始讲笑话了。
We were all part of one peer group. But we weren't all geniuses, you know? Robin Williams and people of that genre, how could I compete with those guys? They were geniuses.
我们都是同一个同伴群体的一部分。但我们并不都是天才，你知道吗？罗宾·威廉斯和那个流派的人，我怎么能和那些家伙竞争？他们是天才。
I mean, Robin Williams, I used to pick him up in front of Chase's to drive him out to the Newport Beach Laff Stop. And I was the closing act. Well, he would get up and, in the middle, do 30, 40 minutes. It was killer stuff! I couldn't compete with that.
我是说，罗宾·威廉斯，我过去常在蔡斯（Chase's）门前接他，开车送他去纽波特海滩的Laff Stop。我是压轴。好吧，他会上去，在中间做30、40分钟。那真是杀手级的东西！我没法和那个竞争。
It's true. I'm pretty sure you've heard of Robin Williams, and you've probably never heard of Johnny Dark. But he built a successful career, had small roles on a bunch of popular sitcoms, made good money on the road, supported a family. His most memorable role might be this one.
这是真的。我很确定你听说过罗宾·威廉斯，而且你可能从没听说过约翰尼·达克。但他建立了一个成功的职业生涯，在许多受欢迎的情景喜剧中扮演小角色，在巡回演出中赚了不错的钱，养活了一个家庭。他最令人难忘的角色可能是这个。
Ladies and gentlemen, please say hello to Johnny, the world's oldest page, I think.
女士们先生们，请向约翰尼问好，我想是世界上最老的通讯员。
In the 2000s, David Letterman pulled his old friend Johnny Dark into the spotlight for a series of guest appearances on The Late Show, giving Johnny a little bit of the fame and recognition he had always wanted. The bit was that he was the world's oldest CBS page, an intern, basically, who'd been killing time in the bowels of the Ed Sullivan Theater for 38 years. The character was crappy and defiant. He had no interest in the show and mainly wanted Letterman, the big-shot host, to leave him alone.
2000年代，大卫·莱特曼将他的老朋友约翰尼·达克拉入了聚光灯下，在《深夜秀》中多次客串，给了约翰尼一点他一直渴望的名声和认可。这个桥段是他是一个世界上最老的CBS通讯员，基本上是个实习生，已经在埃德·沙利文剧院的深处浪费了38年时间。这个角色很烂且叛逆。他对节目没兴趣，主要想让大卫·莱特曼这个大牌主持离他远点。
Oh, I'm sorry, Johnny, you can't-- you're not allowed to smoke in the theater. I'm sorry.
哦，抱歉，约翰尼，你不能——你不被允许在剧院抽烟。抱歉。
Well, remind me to bring that up next time you blow smoke up a celebrity's ass.
好吧，提醒我下次你吹捧名人的时候带上这个。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Before I talked to him, I sort of assumed that Johnny Dark was going to be a lot like that character, that he'd be bitter about his long and miscellaneous career, about never achieving real stardom, like maybe it had driven him crazy, and now he was sitting at home, compulsively making these videos every day, creating his own lonely, private Hollywood. But he said it's not like that. He told me over and over again in different ways that he wasn't bitter.
在我跟他谈话之前，我假设约翰尼·达克会很像那个角色，他会对他漫长而杂乱的职业生涯感到痛苦，因为从未获得真正的明星地位，就像也许它让他疯了，现在他坐在家里，强迫性地每天做这些视频，创造他自己孤独的、私密的“好莱坞”。但他表示不是那样。他一遍又一遍地以不同的方式告诉我他并不痛苦。
No, no, I was grateful. I was thrilled to be with David.
不，不，我很感激。能和大卫在一起我很激动。
He told me he was glad to have had the chance to entertain so many people. He said he was happy. He's 80 years old, living in LA in a house full of little statues, spending time with his grandchildren everyday, wandering around the park, cooking them dinner.
他告诉我他很高兴有机会招待那么多人。他说他很快乐。他80岁了，住在洛杉矶一间摆满小雕像的房子里，每天陪孙子孙女，在公园闲逛，为他们做晚饭。
Making pizza for them.
给他们做披萨。
There was one moment, though, when he finally admitted that it has been frustrating sometimes.
不过，有一个时刻，他终于承认有时确实感到沮丧。
I feel sort of a love-hate relationship with showbusiness in the fact that I've been close to so many big things that didn't come true. It couldn't come through. It's really tough.
我对演艺界有一种又爱又恨的感觉，因为我离那么多没成真大事太近了。它没能成功。这真的很艰难。
Showbusiness is tough. But it's fun initially, and then it gets tough. And it gets tougher.
演艺界很艰难。但起初很有趣，然后就变得艰难了。而且它变得越来越艰难。
I wouldn't want my grandkids in showbusiness. I really wouldn't. I mean, I was born to it. But if you can do anything else in the world, do that. Don't get in showbusiness.
我不希望我的孙子孙女进入演艺界。我真不希望。我是说，我生来就属于它。但如果世界上你能做别的任何事，就去做那件事。别进演艺界。
So you're saying you didn't have a choice but to do this. Why? Just because you loved it too much?
所以你的意思是，你别无选择只能做这个。为什么？只是因为你太爱它了？
It was in my heart, just like my wife. When I met my wife, I had no choice. I didn't want to get married. But that's what love is. Love doesn't give you a choice, I don't think. And neither does showbusiness.
它在我的心里，就像我妻子一样。当我遇到我妻子时，我别无选择。我不想结婚。但那就是爱。爱不会给你选择，我不认为。演艺界也不给。
I was always fascinated by guys that were so smart, like Jerry Seinfeld and people like that that could put the show and the business together. I always had trouble with the business. Even now, everything that I do, over 1,000 songs I've sang on YouTube, will I be paid for that work? Will I be paid for that effort?
我一直着迷于那些非常聪明的家伙，比如杰瑞·宋飞（Jerry Seinfeld）那些能把表演和商业结合起来的人。我处理商业总是有困难。即便现在，我所做的一切，我在YouTube上唱了1000多首歌，我会为那份工作获得报酬吗？我会为那份努力获得报酬吗？
No. Why do I do it? Because I have no choice.
不。我为什么这么做？因为我别无选择。
The word "entertainer" sounds maybe kind of casual. You do a little of this, a little of that. Do it well enough, everyone's happy.
“艺人”这个词听起来也许有点随意。你做一点这个，一点那个。做得足够好，每个人都高兴。
But Johnny Dark is not a casual guy. And he's definitely not a casual singer. Thanks to these videos, his life is nonstop rehearsals, nonstop singing.
但约翰尼·达克不是一个随意的家伙。他也绝对不是一个随意的歌手。多亏了这些视频，他的生活是不间断的排练，不间断的歌唱。
I made it sort of a discipline thing for me. I have to know exactly every line every single day. So every morning, I get up, and it's just like I'm taking a gig.
我把它变成了我的一门纪律。我每天都必须确切地知道每一行歌词。所以每天早上，我起床，感觉就像在接演出。
I get in the shower. I go over the song. I listen to the song on tape while I'm shaving.
我在淋浴时排练。我刮胡子时听着歌带。
But don't forget, I've listened to that song for 24 hours off and on with the kids. When I'm with the kids at the park, I sing the song aloud in a certain area where I don't bother anybody. But no, I rehearse all the time. I've got it down. So yesterday, me singing "Lollipops and Roses" didn't exist. Today it does exist.
但别忘了，我和孩子们断断续续地听了那首歌24小时。当我和孩子们在公园时，我在某个没人打扰的区域大声唱歌。但没有，我一直在排练。我练好了。所以昨天，我唱的《棒棒糖与玫瑰》不存在。今天它存在。
(SINGING) Bring her nice things, sugar and spice things, roses and lollipops, and lollipops and roses.
(歌唱) 带给她好东西，糖和香料，玫瑰和棒棒糖，棒棒糖和玫瑰。
Basically, I'm thinking about the song. I'm thinking about doing it right. I'm thinking about how I was terrible. I'm thinking about how that was good.
基本上，我在思考那首歌。我在思考如何把它唱好。我在想我当时表现有多糟。我在想那表现有多好。
I'm just thinking about the art. And sometimes I'll do a song four or five times. I'll even post it on YouTube. And then I'll listen to it and I'll go, I don't hear it. I don't hear the music.
我只是在思考艺术。有时我会把一首歌唱四五遍。我甚至会发布到YouTube上。然后我听了它，我就想，我没听到。我没听到音乐。
And I'll delete it. And then I'll do it again. And if I don't hear it, I'll delete that. And then I do it again, and if I hear it, then I'll post it.
然后我会删了它。然后再唱一次。如果我没听到，我会再删了它。然后我再唱一次，如果我听到了，那我就发布。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
I mean, is there a sense in which these songs are more for you than for anyone else?
我的意思是，这些歌是否更多是为你自己而不是为别人唱的？
They're as much for me as for anyone else, yeah. They're as much for me because I want to keep this working as good as it could possibly work, you know? I meant my brain by that. I was pointing to my brain.
它们既是为我唱的，也是为别人唱的，是的。它们更多是为我唱的，因为我想让这个大脑尽可能好地运转，你知道吗？我指的是我的大脑。我刚才指着我的大脑。
He also posts the videos on Facebook. And he gets more engagement there-- not a massive amount, but 30 or 40 likes per video. And people show up in the comments section, reminiscing about the old songs they loved growing up.
他也把视频发布到Facebook上。他在那里获得了更多的参与——不是海量，但每个视频有30或40个赞。人们在评论区出现，怀念他们成长过程中喜爱的老歌。
But Johnny still directs people to his YouTube page. He says that's his personal archive, the thing he's building. He wants to leave it behind for his grandchildren. I like to picture them decades from now, sitting around a laptop, listening to grandpa singing "Me and My Shadow" or "The Very Thought of You."
但约翰尼仍然引导人们去他的YouTube页面。他说那是他的个人档案，他在构建的东西。他想把它留给孙子孙女。我喜欢想象几十年后他们坐在笔记本电脑旁，听爷爷唱《我和我的影子》或《非常思念你》。
But there's one last reason Johnny makes videos everyday. He still has showbiz ambitions. He's currently pitching a sitcom, in fact, with a friend of his. But on YouTube, he doesn't have to pitch.
但约翰尼每天制作视频还有一个原因。他依然有演艺抱负。事实上，他目前正与一位朋友推销一个情景喜剧。但在YouTube上，他不需要推销。
And I think that might be the main reason he's been doing it for so long. Maybe there aren't many people there watching. But at the same time, there's no one there to stop him.
我认为这可能是他做这么久的主要原因。也许没多少人在看。但与此同时，也没人能阻止他。
I think the fact that I could sing and not have an audience, and not depend upon anybody-- I don't have to rehearse for anybody. I don't have to ask anybody's permission. I can greenlight myself everyday.
我认为我能唱歌却没有观众，不依赖任何人的事实——我不必为任何人排练。我不必征求任何人的许可。我可以每天给自己开绿灯。
Do you know how hard that is to do after waiting for somebody to say, OK, we'll greenlight you. Let's go with Johnny Dark. OK, let's go with Johnny.
你知道在等待别人说，“好的，我们给你开绿灯。用约翰尼·达克吧。好的，选约翰尼。”之后，做到这一点有多难吗？
Of all the things that I've done-- and there are tons of things-- there are tons of other things I haven't done, where you go, oh, I wish I had that part. I came close to-- and that's what singing is. So I keep my self-esteem. I don't have to say, well, you walked away from it, man. You walked away from it. Well, I didn't walk away from it. I may not be getting big bucks for it, but I didn't walk away from it, man. I'm entertaining everyday.
在我所做的所有事情中——那有成吨的事情——还有成吨我没做过的事情，你会想，哦，我希望我有那个部分。我差点就——这就是唱歌的意义。所以我保持了自尊。我不必说，好吧，你逃避了它，伙计。你逃避了它。好吧，我没逃避它，伙计。我可能没因此赚大钱，但我没逃避它，伙计。我每天都在娱乐。
I didn't walk away from it. I'm in the business. My toes are in the water.
我没逃避它。我还在这一行里。我的脚趾还在水里。
You see Johnny smiling in the videos, eager to please. But underneath it, this whole project is kind of aggro, defiant. He's going to decide when it's over, and it's not over yet.
你看到约翰尼在视频中微笑着，急于取悦。但在那之下，整个项目有一种攻击性，一种挑衅。他会决定什么时候结束，而现在还没结束。
Like, I don't need any of you. Sure, I want an audience, but I don't need one. I'm here to entertain. And I'm going to be here, whether you're entertained or not.
就像，我不需要你们任何一个人。当然，我想要观众，但我不需要。我是来娱乐的。无论你们是否被娱乐，我都会在这儿。
(SINGING) What a world. Man, this is the life. Hey, now, I'm in love.
(歌唱) 多么世界。伙计，这就是生活。嘿，现在，我坠入爱河。
Kelefa Sanneh, he's a staff writer for The New Yorker Magazine.
凯莱法·桑内，他是《纽约客》杂志的特约撰稿人。
Act Four. So the title of today's episode, "The Daily," is also the title of a podcast. If you're hearing us, you've probably heard them too. And so with them in mind, we end today's show with this.
第四幕。所以今天剧集的标题，“每日”，也是一个播客的标题。如果你能听到我们，你可能也听过他们。所以考虑到他们，我们以这个结束今天的节目。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Here's what else you need to know today. The atoms in your body replace themselves. So you are not the same person you were a year ago-- or anyway, around 98% of you is not the same person. The only atoms in our bodies that seem to stay with us our whole lives are buried in the DNA of some of the cells in our brain and our heart, and also in our bones and teeth.
这就是今天你需要知道的其他事情。你体内的原子会自我更新。所以你不是一年前的那个你——或者说，大约98%的你不是同一个人。我们体内唯一似乎终身陪伴我们的原子埋藏在某些脑细胞和心脏细胞的DNA中，也埋藏在骨骼和牙齿中。
Here's what else you need to know today. Fruit Loops-- they're all the same flavor. The yellow ones, green ones, red ones-- all the same. Here's what else you need to know today. We spend 10 minutes a day looking for stuff we've lost. That's the average person on the average day, of course. The number comes from a survey of 3,000 adults. 14 people in the survey said the amount of time for them searching for lost items was over an hour a day.
这是今天你需要知道的其他事情。水果圈麦片（Fruit Loops）——它们都是一样的味道。黄色的、绿色的、红色的——全是一样。这是今天你需要知道的其他事情。我们每天花10分钟寻找丢失的东西。当然，这是普通人平均每一天的数值。这个数字来自一项针对3000名成年人的调查。调查中有14人说他们每天寻找丢失物品的时间超过一小时。
Here's what else you need to know today. 1 million species are on the verge of extinction. It's 1/4 of all mammals, 1/5 of all reptiles, 1/6 of all birds. So as we fix our hair and scroll through Twitter and try to figure out what movie we're going to watch next, that's still happening. Here's what else you need to know today.
这是今天你需要知道的其他事情。100万个物种处于灭绝边缘。那是所有哺乳动物的1/4，所有爬行动物的1/5，所有鸟类的1/6。所以当我们整理发型、刷推特并试图弄清楚接下来看什么电影时，这一切仍在发生。这是今天你需要知道的其他事情。
And by "you" this time, I mean you. You need to know that last night, when you put that plate of food in front of me, it was hard not to stare at it like a character bonked on the head in a cartoon. An average Thursday, you take cabbage, onions, carrots, coconut milk-- I don't know what else-- the most ordinary stuff in the world and somehow give me something that is better than anything I could have imagined, like you always do with everything you do. Our life is so different from anything I thought would ever happen to me.
这次说的“你”，我指的是你。你需要知道，昨天晚上，当你把那盘食物放在我面前时，我很难不盯着它看，就像卡通片里被敲了脑袋的角色一样。一个平常的周四，你拿卷心菜、洋葱、胡萝卜、椰奶——我不知道还有什么——世界上最普通的东西，却以某种方式给了我比我所能想象的任何东西都好，就像你做的每一件事一样。我们的生活与我曾想过会发生在我身上的任何事都太不同了。
Here's what else you need to know today. When I was a kid, at night, sometimes after dinner, my mom and I would sit in the kitchen and talk. And I don't remember about what, but I remember the feeling of it was just, we were really listening to each other and hearing each other in that way that doesn't always happen.
这是今天你需要知道的其他事情。当我还是个孩子时，晚上，晚饭后，我和妈妈有时会坐在厨房聊天。我不记得聊的是什么，但我记得那种感觉，就是我们真的在倾听彼此，在那种并不总是发生的层面上理解彼此。
It felt close. In my memory, the room is dimly lit. Sometimes my dad would come to the door of the kitchen, lit from the hall light behind him, and see us there, talking quietly, and not join in, but just stand there, apart from us.
感觉很亲近。在我的记忆里，房间光线昏暗。有时我爸爸会来到厨房门口，被身后大厅的光照亮，看着我们，在那儿安静地聊天，没有加入，只是站在那里，和我们保持距离。
And I remember a little panic, like, oh, I hope he doesn't feel left out. I hope he doesn't feel jealous. I hope he won't get mad.
我记得有一点点恐慌，就像，哦，我希望他不会感到被排斥。我希望他不会感到嫉妒。我希望他不会生气。
I was-- I don't know-- seven or eight, feeling this mix of protectiveness towards him and fear, which-- I don't know-- is funny to think about today. My mom, long dead, my dad, getting up there, needing help with stuff that he never needed help with before. All that's left of that feeling is the protectiveness part. The atoms of our bodies replace themselves so many times over that things between us have become very simple, which I suppose is the best case of what can happen between parents and kids. But it doesn't always feel that way.
当时我——我不知道——七八岁，感受着这种对他的保护欲和恐惧，这——我不知道——今天想来很有趣。我妈早已去世，我爸，年纪大了，需要他在过去从未需要过帮助的事情上的帮助。那感觉剩下的唯一东西就是保护的那部分。我们身体的原子自我更新了太多次，以至于我们之间的事情变得非常简单，我想这可能是父母和孩子之间能发生的最好情况。但这并不总是那种感觉。
[MUSIC - "AIN'T NO PLACE LIKE HOME" BY MICHAELOUS]
[音乐 - 《AIN'T NO PLACE LIKE HOME》，迈克尔斯（Michaelous）演唱]
Well, today's show was produced by Diane Wu and Tobin Low. The people who put together today's show include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Damien Graef, Andrea Lopez Cruzado, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ari Saperstein, Alissa Shipp, Laura Starcheski, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
好吧，今天的节目由黛安·吴（Diane Wu）和托宾·洛（Tobin Low）制作。今天参与节目的人包括比姆·阿德温米（Bim Adewunmi）、埃尔纳·贝克（Elna Baker）、本·卡尔霍恩、达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）、达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）、安德里亚·洛佩兹·克鲁扎多（Andrea Lopez Cruzado）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、阿里·萨珀斯坦（Ari Saperstein）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、劳拉·斯塔切斯基（Laura Starcheski）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）。我们的总编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的资深编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。
Special thanks today to Noreen Rizvi, Farah Abbas, Xiangqian Wu, Emmet Newlin, Sam Dolnick, Chris Wood, Stuart Pimm, Logan McCarty, Janelle Hamaker, Eric, Tony, Laura, and the rest of the Brown family, Bruce Shapiro, Michael Lynch and the Alzheimer's Association, Don and Carrie Cole from The Gottman Institute. And thanks to Matt McGinley for covering "The Pink Panther Theme" for us. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. You can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos. There's lists of favorite shows that we recommend. There's tons of other stuff. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
今天特别感谢努琳·里兹维（Noreen Rizvi）、法拉·阿巴斯（Farah Abbas）、吴向前（Xiangqian Wu）、埃米特·纽林（Emmet Newlin）、山姆·多尼克（Sam Dolnick）、克里斯·伍德（Chris Wood）、斯图尔特·皮姆（Stuart Pimm）、洛根·麦卡蒂（Logan McCarty）、珍妮尔·哈马克（Janelle Hamaker）、埃里克（Eric）、托尼（Tony）、劳拉（Laura）以及布朗家族的其他成员、布鲁斯·夏皮罗（Bruce Shapiro）、迈克尔·林奇（Michael Lynch）和阿尔茨海默病协会、来自戈特曼研究所（Gottman Institute）的唐（Don）和卡丽·科尔（Carrie Cole）。还要感谢马特·麦金利（Matt McGinley）为我们翻唱《粉红豹主题曲》。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。你可以免费在线收听我们超过700集的档案。此外，还有视频。有我们推荐的最喜欢的节目列表。还有成吨的其他东西。再次说明，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He and I are were out at dinner. And I got up to go to the restroom. When I came back, he was eating my burger. I was like, Torey! What the hell? He said it was my fault.
《美国生活》通过公共广播交换系统PRX传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。他和我当时在外面吃晚餐。我起身去洗手间。当我回来时，他正在吃我的汉堡。我就说，托里！搞什么鬼？他说那是我的错。
You walked away from it, man. You walked away from it.
你逃避了它，伙计。你逃避了它。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "AIN'T NO PLACE LIKE HOME" BY MICHAELOUS]
[音乐 - 《AIN'T NO PLACE LIKE HOME》，迈克尔斯（Michaelous）演唱]